even as basic a thing as flipping a
device from portrait to landscape
orientation might change the best
interface pretty dramatically like this
audio recorder i wrote where the best
way to layout the interface changes in
landscape mode this isn't just reflow
and percentage sizes i needed to change
some more dramatic styling to make this
interface work well
in today's landscape you should really
think of your designs in terms of three
main scenarios
phone tablet and desktop
these may share some design
characteristics of course and they'll
certainly share data but you should
consider the optimal experience for each
of these scenarios separately as you
build your design